I'll tell you a little bit about me
just realize this the other day every
woman who has ever wanted to have sex
with me
has 100% success rate I am originally
from Royston Georgia the home of Ty Cobb
the racist baseball player from 1901
here's how racist he was they called him
a racist in 1901 you know a racist you
had to be to be too racist for 19:01
means there were Klansmen at the game
like it's dudes a big what the heck top
my whole town's got a weird racial thing
the elementary school I went to every
day at recess we played black versus
white soccer that's pretty weird
teachers were just like pick your own
teams like all right black Wow let's go
we'd play but the teachers should have
stopped us there right there they sat
there and watched us lose soccer every
day for six years I didn't say anything
this racist of them I didn't even know
to be racist I was just like man soccer
is hard
sometimes I get a little jealous of
racist people you know how confident
they are I'm friends with all these
hipsters with their mustaches and
fedoras like I sure hope this look makes
me friends maybe this personality will
make me cool racists don't care about
any of that it's why they live to be 110
and are my great-grandmother and they
won't die because there's no stress in
their lives they wake up in the morning
and go I don't like them them them or
them I'm gonna live another 50 years
it's not a coincidence that the oldest
people are the most racist you ever see
on the news or like we're talking to the
oldest man alive today his name's Harold
and he's 115 what do you have to say
Harold news alert there's just as many
slaves in the north is there were in the
south that's all the time we have of
Harold you don't know where that was
going
I'm a big fan of comedy I don't know how
well it ages though you know I'll be
watching one of those old
black-and-white roasts with my dad
nobody's cursing so I don't know when to
laugh
everybody's just up there a - go to
Nebraska and look at a wall and they're
buzlar whoa what did he just tell me do
you know we got him you know I love my
dad he's one of my best friends I just
really hate when he calls me on the
phone I I don't know how he's been alive
this long has no idea how phone works at
all every phone call I get from my dad
is like oh hey Sonos thinking maybe
later Anka got on over to the park maybe
do a little nobody told me didn't have a
fishing license mom Dave your dog was
running through the house use about
twice as big as last time
anyway your mom's not really talking to
me right now but hey if you don't want
to talk to me you got all mad she tried
to put kale in my milkshake I was like
now what the hell is kale
I think kales part of Obamacare so um I
think he's trying to kill everybody
there's just many slaves in the north is
there wearing this out hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography